everyone we would be starting with the
talk in more five minutes and uh in the
meantime you can introduce yourself in
the chat box and hi Julia good morning
you did
hello everyone thank you very much for
joining we're just uh waiting for uh
five more minutes for everyone to join
and so just requesting your patience
for a bit more
thank you everyone for uh joining
again
um
so we will just wait for uh one more
minute to make sure that everyone who
wanted to be here is online
so let me just uh Begin by introducing
everyone to elizarrette she's a
researcher at Tauber bioinformatics
Research Center at hyper University in
Israel and I'm really happy to welcome
you unisa also here thank you for
joining
uh so the workshop is going to be
Hands-On so whenever you have a question
it's best if you're already
registered on the platform and you can
follow along on your computer uh Lisa
will be sharing some uh data that you
can also run on the platform if you
don't have uh an account on the platform
you are welcome to register uh on the
platform and get an account
um so nalika can you just write in the
chat please the email but everyone thank
you very much so you can uh in the chat
you can see the email you can uh
you can write to if you have some issues
with uh
with an account to the platform
uh if you have any questions you can
write in the chat and we will try to
answer them as we go along I'm sure that
Visa will not have uh might not have a
lot of attention paying attention both
to the slides and to the chat but we
will help her along as much as possible
so
um I think we're good
thank you Visa thank you very much for
having me
um yeah as Julia already mentioned uh we
will be going through a metagenomics
section Hands-On uh with preferably
trying it ourselves but if not you can
use this uh presentation and materials
later on to tell or to try it on some
data that you want
um okay then let me start sharing my
screen
okay
um can you see my screen
yes it's visible okay thank you
um so yeah
um I will start with General overview of
the pipeline that we have for
um
our meta Dynamics section
um
so we have actually subsections in there
and uh when we start analyzing our data
which is raw reads in first queue format
we have to of course pre-process them
then after pre-processing when we have
cleaner reads we can create abundance
table so just know how many of the
specific ID we can find in every sample
then we assign taxonomic uh group to
each ID
and we can finally calculate core
metrics
um some iPhone beta diversity there
um and visualize everything and actually
and finally look at the results
okay I have
um the chat window open as well so if
you have any questions
um feel free to write and we can stop
there and uh first thing I wanted to
speak about was where to find the data
to run this analysis yourself
there are two approaches that you can
um well there are two types of data that
you can use this platform with and one
is when you have data yourself you
sequence them yourself or this is the
newest data that you got from your
colleagues or actually you can serve the
internet and find some data that might
be interesting for you and you can
analyze that on the
[Music]
um
online
um and I would like to start with this
by our project
um
I will add the link to the chat
oh wait
so you are on the same page as I am
um
so this is a project about Enderman
syndrome in rats and in Mouse and
um how we find it we just Google a bunch
of things in ncbi try to find a data set
that you're interested in
but from here we actually have to move
to SRA run analyzer to get the metadata
that we need for input and here I'll
give you steps how to find this file
because it can be tricky
so first we have we can look what kind
of data this is
um we see the registration date that
it's really recent one we see who did
this data sets and we can see how many
samples we have there 75 samples
Sr SRA experiments so we click on that
and we move on to
um another information about this data
set this is specific one of the runs
there and
um a bit more information about what
actually was sequenced
the instrument that was sequenced uh
what you that was used uh type of this
analysis the strategy the amplicon
there's also it's also possible to for
example sequence whole Channel sequences
metagenomic then we have this one layout
which is very meaningful for us it's
single end or paired and reads and we
will need it for our analysis and also
construction protocol which is also very
meaningful we have to pay attention what
primers were used for amplification and
what region was Amplified in our data
set
okay let's just remember that we will
need this data
and click on the Run
and we will end up on the SRA
um
website
uh where again we can view all this
information again but we need all our 75
samples in one page
so let's click on SRA study and uh we'll
have another information about what this
project is about and here you can see 75
runs and the total memory usage that was
used and everything we need this
so after we click here we finally are on
the SRA runs lecture web page we again
have all the information about our samp
um experiment and
um here you can see the metadata
so basically this is information for
each run each sample where which
organism it was taken from
um
what is the genotype if it's wild type
or if it's the one that is interesting
for us and the host well a lot of
columns there what we need right now is
to download the metadata file
foreign
I hope you're on the same page as I am
please let me know if I'm moving too
fast we can slow down
um so
after you download the metadata file
um it's normally in txt files comma
separated or it's tab separated but if
you open it in in Excel or in numbers
for example it will look like a table it
will look like something like this
um but let me um
move to another window for a bit
yeah
um in fact it will look something like
this
um so it's pretty huge
um they have all the information here
that we might need
um so it's really
um your concern how if you need the
oldest or if you can just take parts of
it especially if they're the same take
parts of them and just remove this
information altogether because it will
be pretty hard to navigate later on but
please pay attention to some entries
that are interesting for example
the hottest common name
or the scientific name doesn't matter if
for example your research is more
interested in rats than in Mouse you can
only pick this rose and a discard mask
or vice versa doesn't really matter
um
so I encourage you to look through your
metadata and to filter out columns and
rows that are not too interesting to you
because they might
become Troublesome later on in my case
um I was interested only in maths and I
was only interested mainly interested in
a few uh columns especially the genotype
and
um well since I filtered not this but
um okay
so this is my final table
um you can see that I only have a mouse
here already
is it
yep so only Mouse here already and uh
the most interesting for me is genotype
and I left the left rest just in case
and
um
so with this file we can proceed you
have to export it so it will be tapped
delimited or comma delimited
um but it should be a txt file it cannot
be Excel file or something like that
okay
um okay back to the slides
um
I'm not sure if everything goes well
with this file for you
so I will uh send this file in the chat
it's possible Right
it's possible
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
you can send it to me and I'll try to
send it while while you continue
you know just send it to me and Austin
okay thank you yeah
um
thank you for your help Okay so let's
assume you have this file
oh so zoron you successfully did
everything
okay
um so let's move on from here uh if you
have this file ready um and hopefully
Julia will send it if you don't have
this file ready so you can try it out
anyways
um we will have to move on to the
um
T Bar platform
so you already have a link but I will
just send it
um
this link works
um and in the main menu we go
um at the very end
uh the link that uh was sent by someone
Lika and you have to pick metagenomics
chime too
and the first thing that we have to do
is to specify what type of input we have
so there are two inputs
um
I already told you that you can have
manual input when you have all the files
the fastq files on your computer and you
will be uploading them directly
um or you can use ncbi upload when you
only have the metadata the file that we
just looked at together
um and the system will automatically
download all the fastq files according
to the first row which has the IDS which
is pretty handy
um also things that you have to remember
is what is the
um strategy is it single end or period
end analysis
and in case you have the manual upload
there is also a possibility to choose if
it is Multiplex or D Multiplex data
um Multiplex and D Multiplex means that
you have one or several samples
um in one set of files
um if it's one sample then just a fastq
files I'll write and there are several
samples then you will have to have a
metadata that will help you
differentiate between samples inside
these files
however if we're working with ncbi
upload it is always the multiplexed
means each file that will be uploaded
um
it will have it will be by on its own
um so we pick ncbi upload yeah ncbi
upload and single end and clicking
sequences
on the sequences we have to upload our
txt file that Julia just sent the link
to um
in the chat or please download it if you
don't have your file ready yet
so just upload it click options and
we're moving on to the third tab in the
upload system that is
to be uh to pick the variable region so
um for this I'd like to step away from
the platform a bit and talk about what
it is actually being sequenced in case
of amplicon sequencing
and 16s RNA has several variable regions
that are
along the whole 16s region and there are
already
primers that are mostly used for each
region and some regions that are very
popular for example one of the most
popular are before or V3 V4 the
combination or anything
um
it is advised to use the same primers as
were used for sequencing
um
sometimes for sequencing they change the
primers a bit it's possible or for
example they don't exactly use 341
forward primer but maybe they shift it a
bit
um
that also can slightly affect your
results so it is best to use the same
primers as were used
for sequencing but if you don't know
what exactly are with primers like in
our case they just give you numbers they
don't give the sequence
um or even they just give you the region
then on the platform sorry
um on the platform you can pick the
region that
um
that is mentioned in the study for
example for us
it is written that it's V4 region so we
can just pick the four region or if you
know a specific
um
sequence of your primary here you can
pick custom region and just add the
sequence for forward primer and reverse
primer
okay
um so then you are on the platform
you're not sure where to go to the
upload
um
okay we're not in rush so let me share
my
screen okay can you see it
yes we can see okay
um so I'm also on the platform and here
you have to scroll down
to the metagenomics section and Peak
metagenamics chime
it will take you
on this website
and here's the upload system
here we can choose
it didn't work
I'm not sure what is the reason
okay maybe someone can help Sauron
because I'm not sure this is the issue
of the platform
okay
then I'll go back to my slides
so yeah
um after we picked the region in our
case it will be just V4 and the easiest
way and it will automatically add uh the
primers
we hit submit
and we can start building our pipeline
um
let's just go step by step uh preferably
together so first we import the data
into chime this option doesn't really
need any parameters from you
um what it does it just adds all our
information into chime program
the next
filtering samples what it does is
three options and
Jesus
um if you are talking about demo then
you don't have to choose a demo you can
just choose metagynamics chain two
if that helps
so um what this
um
job does it filters our samples to have
at least some number of reads in all of
them and if we do not meet these
requirements the samples are filtered
out
so we have to have at least 100 Tweets
in our samples to keep them
and the last one in the pre-processing
is uh to have
the quality control plots and Graphics
to understand if actually the trimming
that was done is okay with us or we need
to have a stricter trimming there
yeah
okay
um next subsection is pre-processing
able to use getting the abundance tables
for our otus versus samples
and
here we have two algorithms that are
basically denoising algorithm both
um and diplur and in this case we can
use data 2.
um
and next is silver classification so
when you were picking your variable
region this is where it will be used for
uh silver classification the same reads
that you entered will be used to extract
the same regions from Silver database
that already has taxonomic taxonomic
groups assigned to these sequences
and yeah no more options needed because
you already picked your variable region
as before
um the next part is when we want to
remove or preserve some specific
taxonomical groups
for example we don't want any El coriota
or mammals and we only want to have
something up to second level to the film
we can choose this
or actually you can go through
um the file the silver database and see
how the taxonomic file is arranged and
you can use the specific names of the
bacteria if you want to only have them
for example or you can similarly
exclude specific bacteria if that's also
your idea
well then we do the phylogenic and move
on to core metrics and this one is a
tricky thing because here you have to
pick a sampling depth
um what sampling depth actually does
um
at the moment we did not in integrate an
automated way to determine sample depth
so with the new files it sometimes takes
several runs to understand what is the
optimal sample depth in your data
um sample depth sample in depth is a
number of
um reads that will be in all our samples
in order to normalize all our samples
because for example if one sample you
have
20 000 reads and in another one you have
50 Southern treats
um the proportion can be different and
we don't want to really work with
um very different numbers later on
because that will affect our analysis we
wanted to normalize them to have uniform
uh sample size let's say like that
and for that we come up with a number
um that will work best to preserve the
most samples but at the same time and
preserve the most unique features unique
otus but at the same time not have all
the reads because at some point they are
just redundant and they're not giving us
any more unique
otus
so with this number
probably you'll have to play if this
data set is new
um and other refraction refraction is
actually the tool that helps you
understand what is the optimal sampling
depth for you
um here we already
um
integrated an automated way to determine
the maximum value for offer reflection
and you can then view these results and
try to understand what is the optimal
sample that
so after we're done with this subsection
we can move on to uh visualization
subsection it has Alpha diversity beta
diversity visualization and interactive
visualization
so with Alpha diversity
um all the metrics are calculated at the
previous step on the core Matrix and
here we're just
creating files to visualize all that
um we don't have to choose any options
here
um but for beaded uh diversity
visualization you have to choose which
column you are actually interested in
um
you can change it later on but the
statistics will be calculated for this
column which you can really change later
on so for example in my case I'm really
interested in the genotype so I will be
picking the genotype here
and for interactive visualization I am
interested also in the genotype and for
example the sex
um if you're interested only in one
column you can pick it just twice and it
will have it will just have one group
and not two groups
um
and that is it we're done with our
Pipeline and now you will have to wait
for the results
and it may take time
so
I can give you a link
to the pipeline that already worked so
we can look at the results together
okay I'm sending the link
and um let's wait for a few minutes
so you can open this link and
um maybe someone can tell me if they can
use this link all right
yes it seems like it's working
foreign
if something is not clear just stop me
so our main results will be held in
let's say two places
um just to download the files
um as done by the chain Pipeline and you
also can look at the dashboard the
interact dashboard
um first I wanted to sit to show the
files because
just to explain the logic
um each step each job that we looked at
is uh outputted as a zip folder and you
can download for example sofa
classification folder and look into its
files or for example pre-processing and
look what kind of files are there or you
can find download all the files that
have chime um
all the time files and see through them
what exactly do you need but it is
tricky to look at chime files although
we output also txt files but still um
it's a lot easier to look at the
interactive dashboard
that you can
um get to if you click on the external
dashboard
um
I think
I'll move there as well
okay
so this is the pipeline
and I click
interactive dashboard
okay and we have three main windows
the taxonomy bar plot that shows us the
abundance of different bacteria in all
our samples and you can see here the
groups that are actually interesting us
the wild type and the group of interests
um you can navigate through this where
you can see the symbol name and the
percentage
you also can
choose which taxonomic level you want to
look at
let's say film
or something else
um
and we can also check what we want our
group as at the bottom of this plot
um you can try and download uh this uh
as a pictures or you forgot the word you
can download this as a picture or as a
HTML file or a table that um is behind
this
um
so this will give you an idea of
um what is actually inside the file uh
the sample how
um the abundance of
uh the bacteria and all
um another
um another type of data is beta
diversity
um
uh principal coordinate analysis results
that we can see here and our color is
genotype and my symbol I chose it to be
sex if you don't want it you can use
again genotype it will only have two
variables if you want to have several
you can choose several it will have four
now that will have
um different symbols for the sex
um and you can look through it and yeah
in this case we were not very lucky we
don't see any separation here
hope it happens
um and also for Alpha diversity
um
you can also choose which column you
want to see your differences uh yang
this is observed otus here and again
although we see that it's not as wide as
for our group of Interest there's no
significant difference in our symbol at
this point
but you can learn your quartile
quantiles here the numbers the median
value and everything
um
what is this data based on is a table of
abundance uh the one that was used after
the
um the verified table the one that was
done after you came up with the sampling
depth and it was
um unified across the table and you can
also download this table you can export
exactly this one or you can export your
taxonomy data or just verify table or
the metadata anything you want and
um it's also very meaningful to export
this one because
um apart from these here the family name
for example family name is already
integrated or if you want it to be an
order
then you will be having an order in this
tables you will have to yourself try and
merge them together to get this
information
um so
um this is the dashboard and I think
it's very helpful
um but at this moment we're still
working on
um how to improve our dashboard and not
all the utilities are
um in there and I'll go back to my
presentation again
foreign
that is also
given by China
so for example if you upload uh sorry if
you download this file that ends with
chime QC
you will have a file named DMX sequence
2 well
two is this is in my case because I have
a lot of files like that
um you'll just have a file that will end
with qzv
and that are you can upload to a website
um
to send it
named a chime View
the idea of this website is to
here the website the idea of this
website is to visualize all the files
that chime prepares because in China
there are two types of files it's Q z a
which have like tables and everything
and qzb that are made to be visualized
in this um
computer and for example the QC part
where we wanted to see the quality of
our reads we upload this file to the
viewer and here is our plot where we can
see that yeah well
um as we could have expected we have
some bulleted rope at the end
um and we could work on that
or for example if I'm interested in more
Alpha diversity metrics not only
observed otus but additional metrics
because they're for of a diversity
metrics we could also download the zip
folder with Alpha diversity
visualization
and look through our qzb files for
example upload uh the I believe this is
even this
um
giveness and Metric index and you can
also see the box plots here
um and the statistics if this was
um significant or not in our case not
significant
um so that's it from my site
um maybe if anyone has any questions we
could go through them
and
um if not then yeah I believe
this will be available later on and the
presentation as well so you can try it
out yourself
yeah happy you liked it
thank you very much for very informative
talk
and anybody who has questions you're
welcome to write them down Visa will
have a look
and next time Lisa will presents single
cell sequencing analysis on t-bioinfo
platforms or you are welcome to join we
will post this new Zoom talk on the page
and will
send everyone a message about it
I'm sorry can I take a moment I see that
there's a question if it's possible to
use this platform for virus research
um exactly chime is not it cannot really
be used for viruses because for taxonomy
we use bacterial data set but I think
if you change the taxonomical table to
the one that you want that will have
actually viral sequences then it is
possible but it will require some manual
um coding
in addition I just want to oh sorry do
you want to know this part no no it's
fine I also wanted to just let everyone
know that there are several uh sections
of the platform dedicated to analysis of
virus genomes not unkind but and just a
genomic uh
variance haplotypes of viruses so we
have at least two sections that I can
think of that you can use for analysis
of virus genomes
thank you very much for joining again
thank you
thank you for
okay bye